it's the Golden Age of Indian chess and
it's all because of one man vishwanathan
Anand today we're outside the home of
Aruna and vision and to get a peek into
their life let's go Islands
and
I'm excited
hi it's lovely to see you thank you
this is lovely and the first thing that
catches my attention are these chess
boarding pieces can you tell us
something about this where are these
sets from they look Exquisite I mean
most of them have all been given to
Ireland in different chess tournaments
that was that is yadra said that was
given linarus 98 this was given by the
Tamil Nadu chess all India Chess
Federation I think when Allen won in
Riyadh 2017 is Anand very um very
specific that the pieces need to be
arranged properly it's very specific uh
only when his attention is drawn towards
it I think otherwise he doesn't even
know it exists so this is a very
interesting board this was given to an
in 2007 linaris Morelia when he won uh I
I think the whole chess board weighs 27
kgs so I mean I made him carry it all
the way from Mexico to Spain Spain
that's a lot of extra baggage yeah I
mean completely worth it I look around
and the whole house has chests in it
chest and this is a very interesting
painting also if you see it's actually
Don Quixote which is a mythical Spanish
character so instead of the windmills
he's actually fighting chess pieces we
have Arnold's best game you have Bobby
Fisher yeah yeah I mean these are some
of the iconic chess books I mean those
days uh when internet coverage of Chess
tournaments were not so big they used to
have these tournament books that they
would make as a way of remembering the
tournament so some of the Monaco
tournaments I mean very iconic
tournaments were captured in these books
it feels like the whole Space is sort of
a product of Love gifts and tournaments
yes more than anything these are the
memories I think you know like one day
you sit and you look back you use kind
of remember I got this year I got it
there and there's always a story behind
a memory
and this one I mean this is some great
memories I mean this is I mean a wall
which brings us a lot of Pride so all
the world championship medals and of
course all the Padma Awards
and is this where uh you are killed and
I don't usually sit for me is like I
said officially yes like mostly I think
everybody's in front of the TV enjoying
their meals what is Anna's favorite dish
what does he love eating Ireland
actually loves a huge variety of
Cuisines so we actually try and make a
lot of different kinds of Cuisine I mean
if you have to say something that's
close to the heart it will have to be
Rasam and potato Curry I mean that's
like soul food but he enjoys good pastas
Mexican food Lebanese food so we try
making a bit of all this at home and
he's there and what about you I would
just be happy with curd rice
I don't know I think this is the special
room yeah this is the special room so
let's see who's there inside
yeah hi Helen hello wanna come
so this is where the magic happens
happens and this is where all the magic
has already happened yes that's a good
way of putting it this is I keep my
computer here about here I can spiral
someone is this the famous room where
when India has a new Grand Master
there's a tradition that we've heard
about he's invited to your home is this
where
it happens yes we obviously they're
allowed to sit there as well but
invariably they want to come in and have
a look and then this is a nice place
maybe to show me a game or something I
think there are pictures of Prague
coming
vaishali was here vaishali rakshita
Divya came as a one of the Young Adam
all of them coming what are the
conversations that happened here with
the young kids
many of them are tongue-tied so we
usually we get very quickly to why don't
you show me your last game then they
open up a lot chess is a good way to get
them to open up that's my world junior
87. it's difficult to tell you how many
doors that open for me and what what
historical moment it was and when I got
back the chess Oscars
so since you had already got five they
didn't want to give him the same trophy
so they gave him a trophy of a king with
the world in his hand this is anan's
first ever mention in a newspaper oh so
this is his first ever when he was
mentioned we Anand achieved a national
record by winning all the nine rounds to
not a maximum of nine points in the sub
junior Championship but imagine now
tears ravi's daughter rakshita is part
of the West Bridge in just a second I
mean it's so beautiful to see how you
know life comes around it's a world
rapid chess and wine Champion so this
was nit gave me this nice
look at the feeling that Aruna knows all
the trophies and why you want better
than you remember because I cleaned it
because it's true because it's true
favorite thank you so much
action for all the youngsters this
opportunity to actually come here and
witness these achievements and spend
time with you in this stunning room
Anand Aruna thank you so much for this